yes
everybody
oh
okay
that's true
um
you're safe
uh
this
um
okay
so
so
okay
two minute warning to the press briefing
two-minute warning to the front freezing
um
so
so
foreign
so
so
um
hi everyone uh happy friday uh we have a
special guest with us today
on jobs day brian diese our director of
the national economic council
uh who will give some brief remarks on
the jobs numbers and take a few
questions and then we'll proceed with
the briefing
hi everybody glad to be with you today
so you all heard from the president uh
early today
earlier today with his uh perspective on
the may
employment report so i won't uh repeat
uh what he said but i just did want to
provide a couple of contextual
uh uh and a little bit more looking
under the hood
of that uh that report from an economic
perspective
um so a couple of things that i think
were notable from our perspective
first uh beyond the top line
uh strong uh job gains uh and the
now consistent pace of uh over 500 000
jobs a month
for the last four months uh we saw in
may may
uh the largest one month decline in
long-term unemployment
the long-term unemployment rate uh since
2011
so in about a decade that measure is
measuring people who have been
out of work for at least 27 weeks
so for more than half a year and that
number fell by 431 000
this month this is a a really important
indicator certainly for those of us who
have been
watching tracking the economy closely
over the course last several years and
into and through the pandemic
because we know the economic evidence
that
those who are long-term unemployed
tend to have the hardest time getting
back into the labor force
um and eventually find new employment uh
and so
this substantial reduction is an
important indicator of the
um that the health of the labor market
and something that is obviously
very good news for uh those people and
also i think for the economy
writ large second uh is on wages
uh and the president touched on this but
we saw average weekly earnings rise
uh a half a percent uh this month which
uh consistent with the wage growth that
we saw last month
we saw analogous data on aggregate
compensation come out
earlier this week and this again is
uh is it's good news good news for the
american worker
and also consistent with what the
president was talking about when he went
to cleveland
last week around
looking at the broader goals of our
economic recovery to drive toward
full employment and to put our economy
in a situation where we see
sustained job gains but also wage gains
for
american workers third point is just how
we see in this
jobs report uh some of the impact of the
american rescue plan and the specific
elements of that work that were designed
to try to address
challenges uh that we face obviously the
beyond the the direct vaccination effort
uh two of the key
elements of the american jobs plan were
around trying to provide the support
necessary to get schools open
and then in particular to provide the
support for child cares and child care
centers
to actually get more child care centers
open because we know that the more
centers are open the more slots there
are the safe
safe child care environment is a key
element of how
families and parents think about how to
sustain work
uh in the postcovid environment
in may we saw employment increase by 103
000 uh in state and local education uh
that
is a direct result of seeing more
schools open uh
more educator jobs uh good news for
those people who are getting back to
work
but also for the broader economic
recovery
we saw eighteen thousand jobs added uh
in uh child and day care services
again uh you draw a direct line between
the resources that were provided in the
rescue plan
for those purposes and uh the results
we're seeing now
i would also provide the context on that
you know despite that progress we're
still
down 800 000 state and local education
jobs
since february 2020 and we're still down
135 000 jobs in
child care and i think that that's a
reminder of the
depth of the uh of the crisis uh uh
of this pandemic uh the ways that we
have to go
but also i think importantly a reminder
of why it is that we
focused on passing a rescue plan that
would sustain support over the course of
this year
that the rescue plan was designed to not
just provide support for
a day or for a month but over the course
of the year as we understood and
the need to continue to provide support
to continue to build back
uh to a stronger foundation
uh fourth i think that you know we're
looking at this employment report in the
context of
um of a number of contemporaneous uh
economic data points first probably the
most important uh
that provides i think uh additional
reason for economic optimism is that
this report was a snapshot of what of
where we were
on uh may may 12th um and perhaps most
evocatively in just how quickly things
are changing
um where we where we to have been doing
this briefing
uh on the day that this uh uh you know
on a day
in that week uh we all still would have
been masked uh things are changing very
quickly and in fact
since that period an additional 21
million
uh adult age americans have gotten fully
vaccinated
and so we're making progress even even
since this
snapshot in time uh and secondly we're
looking at you know
this job growth in the context of the
overall health and growth of the economy
uh and we uh we saw earlier this week uh
the oecd
significantly increased its economic
growth forecast
to 6.9 for 2021 uh in that report
citing that the american rescue plan and
the the
united states fiscal response likely
adding three to four percentage points
to uh gdp this year
and positioning the us as the president
uh heads to his first g7 as
uh the only uh g7 country the only oecd
country
uh in a position where our future growth
prospects are actually stronger today
than they were pre-pandemic uh
in january 2020. that's the that's only
true of the united states not any other
uh developed country the final point uh
that i will make
uh is a point that you will hear me
repeat as and if and
when i come back and we talk more about
jobs numbers in the future
is that um we are in an unprecedented
situation
uh there's a lot of uncertainty in our
economy we never put too much weight on
any individual data point be it a jobs
report or any other report
we expect there to be ups and downs we
expect there to be
uh bottlenecks as we turn this
economy back on and our focus the
president's focus
is uh is on executing an economic
strategy that is working
we see that in the data from today
but to be patient and think to the long
term
about what the american economy needs
and the american workers need as well
um so with that yeah happy to open up to
you today
thanks brian um you mentioned that now
in the present mission
remarks earlier the administrations have
looked to efforts to
address some of the supply bottlenecks
industry
experts say you know semiconductors
that's a multi-year process to fix that
so what is the administration going to
do to fix some of those
bottlenecks that are raising prices
right now yeah it's a great question so
so first of all i would say
this is an issue that the president has
been focused on
from the campaign and early on uh in
upon taking office that one of the
things that the pandemic has exposed
is the degree of vulnerability in supply
chains
and the need to have a deliberate
strategy to try to build resilience
in our supply chains so that's why the
president actually
on february 25th signed an executive
order tasking an olive government
approach to try to look at
supply chain challenges across a set of
four critical areas one of them being
semiconductors
but also to launch a longer-term effort
to look at supply chain vulnerabilities
and
opportunities across sectors of the
economy
so that um that executive order had a
100-day
time frame associated with it which is
uh which is coming due
at the uh at the end of this week so uh
you can expect to hear
more from us on this topic early next
week uh but in
in short what i would say is look on a
lot of these issues there is no
immediate uh short-term uh you know uh
uh
magic bullet fix we have been at this
issue of semiconductors now
uh uh for some time we've been spending
an enormous amount of time with industry
participants uh
up and down the semiconductor supply
chain uh we've identified some very
concrete solutions that we need to take
um and thinking about a long-term
strategy to actually build resilience so
that we're not
left vulnerable the way that we have
been to supply chain challenges in the
future
some of that is working on bipartisan
legislation to actually fund
a dedicated strategy to build out a
domestic
domestic semiconductor industry in the
united states we're making a lot of
progress on that front
and are optimistic there the other thing
that we will be
looking at um is some areas where we
have seen over the course the last 100
days
bottlenecks emerge that are more
short-term in nature that may not
um connect to a longer term uh
geostrategic
or um uh or uh or
or or strategic supply chain issue but
our
our blockages in part because we're
seeing demand come back in some areas
faster than people uh anticipated
um so whether that's in uh you know
housing and construction uh materials
uh or in transportation and logistics
those are areas where building on the
all of government approach that we have
in place we're going to intend to really
zero in on
are there pragmatic issues that we can
help facilitate um and some of that is
bringing the right industry actors
around the table
uh to really understand where those
bottlenecks are um and uh and whether
there are
ways to unstick them at the end of the
day a lot of that issues are transitory
associated with turning an economy back
on
and supply and demand mismatches that
that the market will work through but we
want to be
doing everything that we can to try to
help facilitate practical solutions
where they exist so we'll have a lot
more to say about the specifics of that
but i think that
hopefully gives you the context so last
month president biden
assessed that federal unemployment
benefits had not contributed or he
didn't see much evidence to the more
lackluster numbers
is that still his assessment for this
month and given how many states are now
going to end them
through the month of june with the
president's comments earlier today about
them expiring in 90 days
should other states consider ending them
sooner or later
so i'd say a couple things about that i
mean the first thing that the first
takeaway from this
report is that we're seeing uh really
robust
job growth and we're seeing in fact
historic job growth
in the context of historic economic
growth so
uh we find ourselves the american
economy now um
the economy is growing faster than any
other major economy jobs are growing
faster than any
other major economy so that's the that's
that's the that's the immediate context
um with respect to uh uh the uh the ui
benefits uh you heard the president
earlier today
this the the uh that program was
designed as a
temporary uh lifeline uh the ui
program itself provides a critical uh
support network to
uh to the american people and the
american economy
uh and those uh those temporary the
temporary boost
is slated to now expire in 90 days and
as the president said
um that's appropriate um with respect to
some of the state changes i just just
the important context which i think was
implicit in your question but just to be
clear
is that none of those state none of the
states have actually eliminated the
um any benefits uh yet
some states will initiate that process
over the course of the next uh several
weeks but in
many cases what we're talking about is
states making changes to
uh benefits for four weeks six weeks
eight weeks before
the expiration that is um uh that that
will happen
uh under current law so uh so as we
look at where we are in the economy we
see
uh strong job growth 500 000 jobs a
month on average last four months
uh the us outpacing uh uh every other
uh major uh uh economy uh in the world
and we see reason to really focus on
what are what are
actually going to be the drivers to
accelerate this recovery and then
sustain it for the long term
and that's where you'll see the
president's continued focus is on
finishing the job on vaccinations
delivering benefits to get schools open
to get child care available um and
focusing now now is the right time to
focus on what are those investments that
are actually going to sustain us not
just through
a rapid and recovery but into
full employment and the kind of
productive investments that you see in
the jobs plan in the fitness plan
though the question was similar to
monica so i'll ask another one
um how do you explain the drop in
construction jobs
last month wasn't this a sector that was
actually revving up
yeah so it's it's a great question i
think if you look under the hood
in employment uh in the establishment
survey what you see in may is
job gains very broad-based across
almost all sectors uh job gains um
we did see uh you know we did see a
reduction uh in construction i think
that you know the first thing i would
say to that is that
in any given month you see some
movements up and down and so you'd never
want to read uh too much into one month
but
um uh you saw construction drops
increase in the prior month
we saw manufacturing jobs inc decline in
the prior month and up this month
um i think but so you don't want to read
too much into uh one individual month
but i do think that some of this is
connected to the prior question where
we are as we as this economy recovers
we're seeing some supply chain
bottlenecks
we're seeing some mismatches between
supply and demand
um and we as we anticipate those to be
short term
uh they are still you know uh they're
still causing uh bottlenecks so we're
seeing that in different sectors of the
economy i think some of that may be
what's going on in the uh
in in the construction uh sector as well
so uh so i think you know bottom line we
saw broad-based job growth uh over the
course of may and i think that that's
the most important takeaway
and at the same time you can expect the
administration to be
really laser focused on those places
where we are seeing those bottlenecks
um trying to make sure that we're doing
everything that we can in a practical
level to try to help
unstick those temporary issues i just
want to clarify really quickly
because you didn't say yes or no does
the president still feel that these
enhanced jobless benefits are not
discouraging people
from finding jobs the the the president
i just i'll just you know restate with
president said today the president
believes that
the temporary unemployment benefits and
the temporary boost to those benefits
has provided a critical lifeline that
that lifeline was designed to be
temporary and to
uh expire uh in about 90 days and that's
uh that's that's that's appropriate um
and i would you know
also just put that in the context of
that is a
that is a a very short-term issue where
most states you're talking about a set
of weeks
and really as we look forward and are
focused on what are the things that are
really going to drive the durability of
this economy
going forward you're going to see the
president continue focused like
a laser on the vaccination program
the president's identified and
recognized before coming into office
that there would be no economic recovery
if there wasn't a viable
vaccination strategy we're seeing the
progress in the vaccination strategy
help
to help to drive economic gains help to
make it possible for more people to feel
comfortable and capable to go back to
work and we anticipate that as we
continue to succeed on that front we
continue to make investments in things
like
uh school opening and child care and
otherwise we're going to be able to
sustain
this progress going forward
infrastructure
talks we will have a status report on
that later this afternoon yes
stay tuned more to come thanks guys okay
thank you so much ryan let's do this
again next month
okay um a couple of
items for all of you um
starting this weekend as we noted the
other day uh we will and with
collaboration and support we will be
launching our national month of action
um so that is exciting we've outlined a
lot of those specific details but it's
starting this weekend so i wanted to
note that
i also wanted to give you all an update
that today the u.s government
delivered 1 million doses of the johnson
johnson vaccine to the republic of korea
the friendship and alliance between our
two countries run deep
especially in times of great need and
hardship as was noted when
uh the president uh hosted uh it hosted
the south koreans uh here just a few
weeks ago
this was done in order to ensure the
safety and readiness of u.s and rok
military forces
and today thanks to a whole of
government effort we are delivering
on that promise on i would just note
again that uh
our plan our commitment to deliver 80
million doses is five times more than
any
other country and 13 of the us supply
and we're committed to doing that
by the end of june also would note the
vice president is traveling to mexico
and guatemala
next week in her role overseeing
diplomacy toward the northern triangle
in mexico
she lands in guatemala on the evening of
june 6th she'll be on the ground there
until the evening of june
7th before flying to mexico then she'll
be in mexico until the evening of june
8th
she'll meet with the president of
guatemala the president of mexico
and as well as community leaders
innovators on entrepreneurs and u.s
embassy personnel and i'm sure they'll
do many
readouts from there uh the week ahead on
monday the president
will meet with a native secretary
general general stoltenberg at the white
house
the president and secretary general will
discuss the june 14th
nato summit in brussels and many issues
on the nato agenda
including reinforcing transatlantic
security in the face of challenges
with from russia and china they will
also discuss adapting
nato to address to threats like cyber
attacks and climate change
while continuing to ensure a more
equitable sharing of responsibility
among allies
as we've said revitalizing our alliances
is a priority for this administration
and our alliance with nato is a big part
of that as you all know
on wednesday the president first lady
will also be traveling to the united
kingdom
for their first stop for their first
overseas
trip uh and we'll have one of the
members of the national security team
hopefully at the highest level we're
working on schedules
on monday to do a full preview of the
trip for all of you
um last thing i would note
i think that was it actually zeke go
ahead uh thanks jen um
looking ahead to that trip the back end
from russian president vladimir putin he
had some comments today where he was
suggesting that he did not expect any
concrete breakthroughs i was hoping you
can describe what the president hopes to
get out
of that meeting and is the president
going to commit to raising
uh issues like the imprisonment of
following
the president of american citizens in
russia directly with president putin
face to face
well um first i would say that the
president never holds back in raising
human rights issues
the detainment of activists
with the russian president and certainly
as
our readout made clear when he spoke
with him directly uh he didn't hold back
uh in that conversation i don't expect
he will when they meet
net in two weeks at the summit uh in
terms of the focus of the summit um
you know i think the we'll have more to
preview on monday but as i've noted in
here previously
i think the president expects to raise a
number of issues including
ukraine and uh what we've seen as
aggressive behavior at the border
by the russians uh he also will raise um
cyber
activity uh malign activity problematic
activity harmful activity we've seen
uh take place of course there is the
solar winds hacked uh but also
the ransomware hacks as we've talked
about uh the the
actions of criminal groups uh within a
country there's a responsibility of the
leaders of that country to take action
and
there's no doubt president biden will be
raising that directly in that
conversation
uh i don't think we're setting this up
uh to be a uh
meeting where there will is going to be
um you know a a
an outcome that resolves every issue or
every
challenge in our relationship we expect
there's still to be challenging
conversations moving forward but
it's an opportunity to discuss areas
where we uh where we have mutual
interest
like nuclear uh nuclear security and
stability
and also to raise issues where we have
concern and then we expect that
this to be a form for that face to face
um severally um president just got back
from a couple days
at the at the beach heading into the
summer travel season it is
should we expect to hear from the
president encouraging americans
to travel particularly domestically as a
way to stimulate the economy and to
spend their money
here at home is sort of as the pandemic
seems to be
waning and travel does seem to be
picking up is that is there to be a
pivot from the
on the part of the president going
forward to encourage americans to
get out there and spend money well i
think the president will continue to
encourage
americans uh to safely get out there uh
into their communities especially
vaccinated americans who
are safer to travel to go to restaurants
to not wear masks and
certainly we abide by cdc guidelines as
you know but
president went to a restaurant just last
weekend with the vice president last
weekend on monday
with the vice president they had a meal
something he he hasn't done a lot of
most americans haven't done a lot of
over the last year and a half
uh so certainly he will he will lead by
action
and continue to encourage americans to
take advantage of the benefits of being
vaccinated and for those who are not
vaccinated
to get a shot so they can take advantage
of those benefits themselves
and so one last one for me uh this
friday uh has the president been briefed
on the
unidentified aerial phenomena report and
is he satisfied with conclusions does he
want additional work in that space
uh because it's friday it's always a
little wacky on friday so
let me first say that we know there have
been press reports
about the status of this report this is
a dod report and so i'd certainly refer
to them on the status of the report
their work with odni is ongoing uh
we the team's actively uh working on it
but it's not at a conclusion phase as i
understand and i think they've commented
from their building
i will say that we take uh reports of
encouraging incursions into our airspace
by any aircraft identified or
unidentified very seriously
and investigate each one uh safety and
security
of our personnel of our operations are a
paramount concern there's a requirement
to put out this report and certainly our
appropriate teams are working on
finalizing
we've done it i don't have any update on
internal briefings now
go ahead there seems to be a bit of a
shift in tone
here because last month the president
was pretty adamant that he did not
believe that these enhanced
unemployment benefits were playing a
role or factoring into people's
decisions not to
get back into the jobs market today
though he's underscoring that these
benefits are simply temporary set to
expire in 90 days so
which is it yes or no does the president
believe that these unemployment benefits
are playing a role here well i think we
shouldn't lose sight of some basic facts
here which is that
the those governors who have made the
decision as they have every right to do
to pull back on unemployment benefits or
not accept them i should say accurately
that hasn't even taken effect in any
state across the country
so in terms of how we're evaluating the
impact we haven't even seen the impact
yet that takes effect in june
it is important for people to understand
uh factually
that the president no one from the
administration has ever proposed making
these permanent
or doing it over the long term and
sometimes i think that that was just an
if
an effort to make that clear in the
public uh
so we understand there's politics at
play here that's okay
every governor is going to make their
own decision at the end of the day
what we see is the biggest driving
factor is vaccines
and individuals being vaccinated uh
feeling safe to go back to workplaces
the fact that child care centers have
rehired that teachers have gone back to
work those are all positive signs
at the end of the day we've created the
president and this administration has
created more jobs than any president any
administration in modern
american history so that's kind of how
we see the jobs
based on the data do you believe that
these benefits are having any kind of
impact in people deciding
not to maybe re-enter the job force
right now well again
i i think that's a really difficult
thing to analyze given
we have created a historic number of
jobs in the last four months
more than any president in modern
american history
so and the jobs the ui benefits haven't
even
been pulled back in any state so it's a
question i'm sure we can have a
discussion about in the next couple of
months as we see what the impact is on
different states or if that's a factor
but we think the biggest factors overall
are
more people getting vaccinated uh more
people being
comfortable and feeling safe going out
into the workforce and
that's uh where we feel there's going to
be an encouraging upward trend
i'm trying to understand what happened
in the last month though because last
month you said you didn't see any
indication of that when looking through
the data i don't think we can evaluate
the data
that hasn't been applied in states
across the country yet and what we're
really talking about from state to state
is
governor's making a decision to pull
back on accepting unemployment benefits
for six weeks or eight weeks
that's it it hasn't even started yet so
i i would leave it to all of you and
your outside analysts to
decide whether that is a big factor in
terms of
economy and data or whether that is a
political discussion we're having
go ahead thanks jen does the white house
have any reaction to facebook's decision
to suspend president trump for two years
was this a reasonable consequence for
what he said
well uh as always it's a decision for
the company to make and any platform to
make and clearly they've come out and
made their decision
our view continues to be though that
every platform whether it's facebook
twitter
any other platform that is disseminating
information to millions of americans
has a responsibility to crack down on
disinformation
to crack down on false information
whether it's about the election
or even about the vaccine as we're
trying to keep the american public safe
and
get more people are returned to normal
out in society and
i think as we look at it we learned a
lot
from president trump uh the former
president uh over the last couple of
years about
his behavior and how he uses these
platforms feels pretty unlikely that the
zebra is going to change his stripes
over the next two years
we'll see so does this decision validate
what president biden has repeatedly said
about mr trump which is that words
matter
well i don't know that it's a validation
i think the president isn't the only one
who thinks that
words do matter words do have an impact
we saw the impact on january 6th of
words
on social media platforms and we've seen
the impact of words
as it relates to disinformation
traveling around the vaccine around
election integrity so of course we think
words matter
this is a decision by a private sector
company we'll see what their evaluation
is a couple of years from now and what
other steps they can take most
importantly
go ahead jen our reporting indicates
that the biden administration is
considering
counter cyber attacks to stop the
ransomware criminals
in russia how big a factor is the
upcoming summit
in that decision making is there a
concern that if you did that before the
meeting in geneva it could derail the
talks
and if it doesn't happen before then
what message does it send
to russia after these multiple cyber
intrusions
well let me first say that we always
reserve the option of responding
to behavior or actions that are
unacceptable
and are harmful and some of those
responses
are seen and some of them are unseen and
we typically don't give a timeline on
that in a public
capacity but i will also note to you
that
when the president when we announced the
invitation to have this discussion
it was also in the same time period
where we announced the in
the uh sanctions that we were putting in
place in response to
uh harmful actions by the russian
government right in response to solar
winds in response to
uh their engagement in our own election
so
we expect this is this is diplomacy in
action here right uh
we will take action when warranted uh
sometimes seen sometimes unseen we
typically don't predict that ahead of
time
uh and we also will look for areas of
opportunity to have a discussion but we
are not having this summit
as a reward we're not having the summit
because
we expect to only talk about areas where
we agree or disagree
and in the president's budget blueprint
there's only about 1.3 billion dedicated
to bolstering
cyber security given what we've seen
over the last few weeks
is that enough are there talks that more
resources need to be dedicated to this
or are you thinking more to leave this
to the private sector for those
companies that we've seen that have been
impacted
yeah it's a really good question i mean
i will say that um
we know that the ransomware threat is
urgent um it's complex
and it's been increasing over the last
several years and you know it feels
new to us over the last couple of weeks
but it has been increasing rapidly
around the world over the last
several years one of the reasons that we
have
initiated a rapid review internally
is because we recognize that threat and
we will assess based on that review
what additional needs there are both
from the federal government
in coordination with congress or from
the private sector
and that reviews focus on uh the
disruption of ransomware infrastructure
and actors working closely with the
private sector
building an international coalition of
course which will be a focus of the
president will be a topic of discussion
i should say of the president's
foreign trip uh expanding cryptocurrency
analysis which we know is a factor given
uh so many of these um ransomware
attacks are
you know if ransom is paid which of
course we don't recommend and don't
advise from the fbi but
it's often done through cryptocurrency
channels and reviewing our own policies
so
that review is ongoing internally uh
with our national security team and
we'll assess what additional needs might
be needed
one last bit of housekeeping last month
you said you didn't have an update but
that you maybe expected the president to
get his first physical
soon do you have anything any update to
provide on that should we expect that to
happen
this summer or is there anything else
you can give me it will definitely
happen this year and when he has his
next physical we will provide that
information transparently to all of you
but i don't have a date for you go ahead
thank jen
what uh the president support a
commission to investigate the initial
u.s
response to coba 19.
a commission in congress or a
presidential commission
i would say if members of congress have
a discussion and want to have a
discussion about that we're happy to
hear from them
but our focus right now as you know
peter is on our own internal
investigation or
internal process i should say using all
of the resources of government
tapping into our data and science
experts to see
what more we can determine over the next
90 days or
less than 90 days about the origins of
of the pandemic mike pompeo is now
saying that when he was the secretary of
state and he was trying to investigate
the origins of copa 19 there the nih
folks were trying to suppress
what he was doing so is there any
concern from the white house that there
may have been people at the nih
who are making policy decisions based
not in science but based on their
personal political beliefs or
preferences
well i really don't have any analysis of
the last administration's
inter working we're still over there and
you see how they operate
here's what we know peter we know that
dr fauci
uh and many members of the nih team
medical and science experts because of
their work over the last 10 years we
have developed
a focus and effort and apparatus to
fight this pandemic and we are grateful
to them for their work
everybody wants to get to the bottom of
the origin former secretary pompeo
president biden democrats and
republicans across the board
we all share a concern about the
challenge and that is the
intransigence at times by the chinese
and providing data and providing
information
we share agreement on that we all want
to get to the bottom of what happened
here
and you mentioned dr fauci there have
been these emails that have come out
through a foia request that uh make it
seem like uh we knew that he had his
hands full at the time trying to figure
out what to do
but it seems like there were times that
he was saying one thing
in email and then coming to this
microphone and saying something else
if that is the case and if that affected
the u.s policy
posture at the time should he be held
accountable
well i've talked a little bit about dr
fauci and dr falchi has been out doing
several interviews himself and answering
questions
on these emails and uh questions that
you all may have
dr fauci is a renowned public servant a
civil servant i should say a career
civil servant
he's overseen management of multiple
global health crises and the attacks
and and and attacks launched on him are
certainly something
we wouldn't stand by uh i understand
there's interest in the emails
he's answered a lot of questions on the
emails i don't think i'm gonna have much
more to add on them from here do you
think the attacks are political
against dr kaushi i i'm going to let dr
fauci speak to
his own defense of his emails from 17
months ago before
this president even took office okay and
then finally
does president biden have a position on
gain of function
research uh well we
have not um as dr fauci has actually
said repeatedly uh we've never approved
any funding for gain of function
research in wuhan i know that's i think
why you're asking the question
i believe some may have been approved or
there was funding approved during the
prior administration there's a framework
i should say this is not meant to be a
criticism
of funding and how it's approved through
different nih programs but i would send
you them to give more of a an
explanation of the funding mechanism and
just
since you mentioned dr thought you again
can you imagine any circumstance where
president biden would ever
fire him no go ahead um
just to follow up a little bit on russia
i know you said repeatedly that this is
not a reward
uh to vladimir putin but it what can you
do in terms of stage management to make
sure that it doesn't become that
i mean become a platform for him to
offer
alternate facts um alternate analysis of
history of what's going on
and and also provide you know a way for
him to
uh damage the opposition within his own
country are you thinking through that
issue
are you how will you address that well
one thing is we're going to bring all of
you with us
um to report on what he says and doesn't
say and
fact check what he says or doesn't say
the other piece is
president biden as you've heard him talk
about has known has engaged with
president
putin in the past throughout his career
uh and he has never
uh one to hold back on when areas where
he has concern
areas where he feels the actions of the
russian government
or russian leadership are hurting the
united states and he certainly has no
intention of holding back
during this meeting publicly or
privately but at the end of the day
our job or our focus is on moving toward
a more stable and predictable
relationship with russia there are areas
where we can
work together uh we've talked a little
bit about you know we renewed uh
start a new start uh early on in the
administration for five years
that's an area we can work together
there are ongoing negotiations uh for
the iran nuclear deal they just finished
their fifth
round of discussions russia is a member
of the p5 plus one
we can have a discussion there at the
same time we also feel that
uh no country should be you know
harboring has a responsibility not to
harbor
criminal individuals who are launching
ransomware attacks and that will
certainly be a part of the discussion as
well
so you're right when we have
conversations with leaders we disagree
with
where we have some adversarial
components of our relationship
it is important to send the message that
we're not validating their actions in
fact we're calling them out on it
but it is also an opportunity
face-to-face to
raise those issues and also to hopefully
move toward a more stable and
predictable relationship moving forward
on infrastructure um
you know is the corporate tax hike that
was originally proposed is that
uh pretty much dead now can we expect to
see it in reconciliation
is there anything else that president
biden plans to offer when he speaks with
the senator today
well since you gave me the opportunity
trevor i i think there's an important
note here
one is that we didn't talk a lot about
uh the the uh book uh line uh
tax taxes that the president talked
about yesterday that we've talked about
a little bit yesterday
the 15 tax that these companies were
asking these companies or we think these
companies should pay that pay no tax no
tax
um that was in his original american
jobs plan proposal it was in the lengthy
fact sheet i'm sure reuters wrote many
stories about
um so that was a component that we
didn't get we didn't have a lot of a
public debate about
but it has been something he talked
about on the campaign it's in our budget
it was in his american jobs plan
proposal in terms of the corporate tax
increases that was also proposed and
certainly has been a more of a public
component of our discussion
you know that's something he continues
to believe corporations can pay more
money
that that's a way to fund his bold ideas
uh there are a lot of ideas that
he wants to move forward on whether it's
extending the child tax credit
universal pre-k uh proposals that he has
put forward in the american families
plan
which we are looking forward to having a
continued discussion about and they're
also a range of pay fors
he has proposed 15 minimum that you just
brought up
is that um did you bring that up because
that's something that yellen is pursuing
on the
international no separate i'm glad you
asked that question uh separate issue
i know it's confusing because the 1515
uh separate issue there is a discussion
as you noted on the global
stage about a global minimum tax um but
this is a this is a proposal the
president talked about on the campaign
trail
uh he proposed in his american jobs plan
and also in our budget
that would even would require you know
would would have companies that didn't
pay any tax wouldn't allow them to pay
zero tax
uh and so we see it as a separate entity
we still believe the tax rate should be
higher than that as the president has
proposed on a court for a corporate rate
can you give us a sense of what your
expectations are for this
discussion is it by phone for instance
with senator capital
oh sure sure every near
the decisional process for a point for
the pressure
uh so they will be talking by phone uh
president and senator capito this
afternoon he'll also be talking with
congressman
defazio and we will be doing readouts of
those conversations they're happening
this afternoon
as we speak perhaps but uh we will
provide readouts
uh i'm not gonna obviously prejudge
conversations but i would say
for the conversation with uh senator uh
capito
uh they've had good faith discussions
there are areas where
of course um you know the president uh
has priorities where he'd like to see
more
including more investment but also areas
uh
including electric vehicle investments
rebuilding veterans hospitals and that's
part of the discussion
as well as well as pay fors and as as
trevor just asked about but as we talked
about about yesterday
what the president put forward he looked
at all of his tax proposals
and what he put forward are ways to pay
for
uh an infrastructure proposal that he
that shouldn't cross any bar or line for
republicans in the senate who say they
won't touch the 2017
tax plan so i think the question really
on that front is
do you think these companies should pay
no tax at all or
15 which is very viable supported by 85
or 84 percent of republicans in the
country does the president believe he's
running out of time to try to
reach a deal or is there runway left
uh there's runway left uh he's going to
have these discussions there are
democrats and republicans uh who are
talking with each other we're going to
engage with them as well and
continue to have a discussion with a
range of interested leaders in congress
about
how we can come together to make a
historic investment in
infrastructure there are some realities
of timelines including the fact that
congressman defazio is leading the
markup of key components of the american
jobs plan
next week key infrastructure components
where there is a big overlap
there is a lot of interest and
excitement by many democrats in congress
about that
so it's not unlimited but we have an
opportunity he's going to talk to
senator capito
this afternoon we're going to see how
those conversations go we're going to
keep a range of pathways open
to move these bold ideas forward randy's
talked about the supply shortage
issue can you talk about any particular
types of
supplies that we're talking about so the
you know with regards for instance
the construction job gains that were
pretty sluggish what are we talking
about your lumber
what what are the powers the government
has to try to address those
well you i know you've covered this
closely as have others lumber is
certainly one of the areas and we've
seen an impact on
the housing market in part because of a
shortage of some of these
supplies that's having an impact on new
builds that's then having an impact on
the pricing for
homes that have been around a longer
period of time i know you know this but
just to
catch everybody else up so okay so um
so um so we've seen that impact and and
we have been doing this 100 day
review certainly looking at how we can
address those challenge and
challenges and issues through the role
of the federal government
is what we'll talk about when we have
more details to share and
uh hopefully that will be next week a
way that you can address supply
shortages i'm just not gonna
i'm not going to get too ahead or ahead
at all of
uh where we will come down in our final
roll out of our supply chain
uh review process is the president
expecting a counteroffer
during this conversation with senator
capito today i think the president's
expecting they're going to have a
discussion a part of negotiation is
seeing how you can come closer to each
other
he's obviously come down quite a bit in
what he originally proposed
uh and hopefully they'll have more uh
they can add to their proposal but we'll
see but it's a discussion not an
exchange of paper well you described
wednesday is a discussion too but
president biden
made a counteroffer kind of to them on
wednesday i i think that might be over
formalizing the discussion there's a
discussion about
where there might be areas of agreement
then obviously she'll
she may have to take things back he may
have to discuss on our ends with
democratic leadership so
it's it's more of a discussion and where
we can find common ground
hear each other out and we'll see um you
know if this continues to be a viable
path forward and we'll continue to
pursue a range of paths and on these
ransomware attacks does the president
view those
as a national security threat
i certainly certainly think the
president views those as a rising
uh national concert security concern uh
and an area where
uh we need to continue to keep our focus
keep our assets uh focus on energy
and uh and brain power on what we can do
to address it that's why we launched
this
rapid review um to take a look at these
four areas of focus
including our own approach through the
us government including how we work at
the private sector
including uh cryptocurrency uh and
uh and also including uh what role we
can have
on the global stage so uh certainly this
is a priority
to him and an area where we will be
spending a significant amount of time in
the coming months okay
my last question just on the unenhanced
or enhanced unemployment benefits
you said that you can't really make a
determination because no states have
actually
cut them off yet the stakes that are
pulling out of the program early
but if nothing has changed shouldn't you
be able to maintain the president's
pretty unequivocal position last month
that they are not encouraging people to
stay home
well if we had that concern we would be
ending them we're not
i mean we there's still seven million
people who are out of work
right and we're talking about 300
benefits for
three more months i think the point i
was trying to make and i think brian was
trying to make is that
the the governors who have made the
decision which they have every right to
do
to pull back on these benefits are
really talking about having them for six
weeks or eight weeks less than we would
already intend to have them
so i think the question is do you think
americans given seven million are still
out of work or more than that
could benefit from eight more weeks or
ten more weeks of these 300
unemployment benefits our view is they
they can
and they should and that's an extra
helping hand we can give to millions of
people across this country
some governors disagree that's okay at
the end of the day in early september
these these benefits will no longer be a
part of the plan
thank you go ahead uh one quick thing uh
housekeeping on russia
and i have something on israel that you
mentioned a few moments ago
that the press will be with the
president when he attends
the summit in geneva can you commit that
he will have a press conference as side
by side with president putin as
as previous u.s presidents have done i
don't know what the format will look
like at this point in time i can
certainly commit that he will
communicate and speak to all of you but
i don't know what the format looks like
yet
um i mean obviously a press conference
would uh
be preferable from but i think he will
answer questions
i don't know what the format will look
like at this point
given the the history of the fairly
recent history
of uh side-by-side uh press conferences
between the u.s president and the
russian
president uh it would make certainly a
a it would be it would be an opportunity
for us to ask
the kind of questions of both presidents
that i think
our president might want to answer well
i know that we will make
president biden available to all of you
and i certainly hope my russian
counterparts makes president putin
available to all of you as well
i don't know what the format will look
like at this point on israel we're a
couple clicks closer
to the formation of the new government
have there been any developments here
in uh president biden's interaction with
either the existing government or the
the new government in formation no not
at this point i think we're going to
allow for that process to move forward
and as you know it may be
a little bit more time before the final
formation is completed what is the plan
for his interaction
with the new government should it be
formed well we have a long and abiding
relationship strategic relationship with
israel and
that will continue to be the case no
matter who is leading the country
you call prime minister bennett upon the
formation of that government
i don't have any calls to predict for
you but certainly he will continue to
engage with his counterparts in israel
and many countries around the world
lastly were you able to nail down
whether or not he had actually ever met
nathalie bennett before you did ask that
question i'm sorry i
did not ask him um i will follow up and
see if i can find that out
um yeah i know well natalie bennett you
would remember the years he was the
chief of staff the prime minister
netanyahu we'll have to do a little data
tracing here
yeah yeah okay go ahead thanks jen um on
the vaccine announcement from yesterday
um can you give an idea at all of how
many doses we can expect are there going
to be monthly surplus shipments going on
to other countries
and would they follow the same 25 75
sort of breakdown uh are there any
discussions about that 80 million doses
by the end of june
but in future months i mean it was said
yesterday we can expect more this summer
so
that's right and we're going to continue
to provide uh part of our supply to the
global community but i don't have
anything to predict for you beyond that
right and um on infrastructure uh can we
expect
the president to meet with senators
romney and manchester is one of the
pathways
that the white house is exploring look i
think as i
as i alluded to a little bit earlier the
president's certainly open to and
interested in continuing to engage with
a range of
members who have an interest in making a
historic investment in our nation's
infrastructure modernizing our roads
rails and bridges and
preparing us to compete over the long
term i know those are two of the members
who have expressed that publicly so we
will see what the future days hold
on the president's trip um can we expect
him to meet with the pope at all there's
been some reporting out there
that he might be meeting with the pope
that's surprising uh i don't think you
can expect that on this trip
go ahead um again on the
the issue of the covet vaccines um can
you talk a little bit about the timing i
know you said about the end of job i
think
but how soon can the other countries
start expecting to receive
these vaccines and also how are you
prioritizing which countries will get
them first
sure well first let me say i mentioned a
little bit earlier 80 million
by the end of june obviously 25 of those
are coming are going bilaterally two
countries we're going to get those doses
out those 25 million
as quickly as we can and we'll provide
you updates as those doses go out so i
had an update this morning about the
this afternoon about the doses that went
out to are okay and we'll continue to
have more updates on that on those doses
um the additional doses of 75 which are
going through kovacs
we've put out kind of our prioritization
of the
regions that those uh will be going to
and part of our focus right now
is on the herculean logistical challenge
of getting these vaccines out to the
right places this is one of the reasons
that we're
doing a large percentage of them through
kovacs because of their capability to do
exactly that
but just to step back and as a reminder
this is not just kind of shipping these
doses overseas
this is also ensuring that we can get
them to the right places that they have
the ability to put them in arms that
they're at the right temperature and so
these are all factors we're considering
as we're determining how to get them out
and the pace
uh in the weeks ahead one more um
the u.s and the eu have begun
discussions on lifting tariffs
on steel and aluminum imports i'm just
wondering if you have an update on what
kind of progress if any has been made in
those talks and if you expect this issue
to come up during the g7
well we certainly expect that our g7
partners will range
will raise a range of issues of concern
to them and a focus and
uh certainly i'd let them to speak to
what those are but the tariffs could be
one of them i don't have anything to
predict for you or preview for you
i have to wrap this up in a minute but
jerry i'm just going to go to you
because i you haven't been here since
i've been here
okay good to see you good to see you um
kind of a parochial buffalo question
okay um
the canadian border has been closed for
a very long time yeah there's a lot of
concern about that
in all the northern tier states right
now and
prime minister trudeau has said that he
has to get 75
of the people in his country vaccinated
before the border reopens
that being the case with the united
states consider opening the american
side of the border
first before uh president prime minister
trudeau would
do that or does there have to be a
bi-national agreement
well i'll first say that as it relates
to borders
canada or mexico we really rely on the
guidance of the cdc and our health
and medical experts so in terms of how
they look at the data and information
i would point you to them and whether
they would do that in a preliminary
fashion or not
certainly any discussion about reopening
a border would be
done through in part through diplomatic
channels but we really are relying and
waiting on the guidance of the cdc
before we make
any next decision there on the border
how much concern is
in the white house about the fact that
here we are it's a summer travel season
there's a lot of concern in those
northern
border states about the economic impact
as well as the personal impact on people
who make
you know couples that may be separated
by the board yeah
we're very sensitive to that jerry and
we certainly know that many people want
to
not just get back to normal but be able
to travel be able to see loved ones some
living on different sides of the border
uh be able to go to restaurants and shop
and even do things
along those lines and we're eager to get
back to normal
whatever that means including reopening
the border but
we have a responsibility during a global
pandemic which we're still fighting
every day
to rely on the advice and guidance of
our medical experts
okay i think we have one more question
remain committed to waiving
uh vaccine patents at the wto today the
eu submitted a counter proposal
saying that uh they don't want to do
that and will the president be pushing
for this issue at the g7
our position hasn't changed on that i
think we have one question
okay uh hello to our uh our
virtual melissa hi melissa thanks for
joining us
hi thank you um right now approximately
16 million public school students in the
u.s live in homes that lack internet
high-speed internet the president
released a plan to ensure that people in
rural areas will have internet access
but reports show
that 13.6 million urban households also
do not have
internet many can't afford it uh what
does the administration plan to do to
increase home internet service for
families in low-income urban
neighborhoods
well it's a great question and melissa
thanks for joining us and hopefully you
weren't waiting too long
i will say that in the parent in the
president's american jobs plan he's
proposed
we're proposing to expand universal
broadband access
across the country to urban and rural
areas to level exactly that playing
field to ensure that kids
in cities as well as in more rural
communities where there isn't as
expensive broadband access
uh have uh have access and we've seen
over the last
year and a half during the pandemic uh
what a disparity it creates
both economically but for kids who are
just trying to get an education
the vice president as the president
announced in his joint session address
is leading this effort
it's an important part of the
negotiation and fortunately one where
democrats and republicans
have a lot of agreement about the need
to move forward on expanding access to
broadband
thank you so much i apologize for this
being short today i have to go do some
regional tv
and anyone those follow-up questions uh
you come up or email me and we'll
talk more thanks everyone
i